[Musique]
ce soir je vais vous raconter une
histoire
je vais vous raconter notre histoire
cette histoire qui nous a transportés à
l'autre bout du monde qui nous a fait
découvrir des terres inconnues mais
d'une beauté incroyable
il y à 7 ans nous avons fait un grand
voyage ce fut un réel tremblement de
terre comme si on se relevait d'un
profond coma alors mais que s'est il
passé
eh bien nous avons découvert un nouveau
langage
vers l'âge de 1 an notre petite fille
marie faisait systématiquement le grand
écart
quand elle passer de la position assise
à allonger tellement facilement que j'ai
voulu essayer
enfin bref je vous passe les détails ce
fut un fiasco
j'ai frôlé le claquage vers l'âge de 2
ans cette même petite marie était assise
dans sa chaise haute pour manger son
goûter elle râlait et semblait parler
tout seul mais en fait pas du tout elle
parlait à une mouche j'ai arrêté
immédiatement mes activités du moment
totalement médusée par cette scène
c'était surréaliste
je vous l'avais mari avait son minuscule
index pointé sur la mouche
elle lui parlait d'un air très
autoritaire lui disant son énervement
eh bien oui la mouche se pose est
successivement sur son bras son nez son
chocolat son chocolat son nez son bras
marie avait beau la chasse et la mouche
téméraires un vrai mouche du coche
recommencer sans cesse alors je ne
pouvais pas rentrer dans ces discussions
parce que ma fille parlait le langage
mouche alors vous pensez sans doute que
je fais partie de ces mères qui n'ont
aucune objectivité sur leurs enfants
mais en l'occurrence pas du tout parce
que cette fameuse mouche à quai après
quelques envolées en zigzag
pour crâner bien sûr a fini par quitter
la pièce marie imperturbable a repris
son goûter et moi eh bien j'avais la
bouche tellement ouverte que j'ai failli
la gober cette mouche vers l'âge de 4
ans cette fois mari était en train de
jouer dans un chambre est la plus un
bruit un peu inquiète je vais voir si
elle préparait une bêtise mari était
immobile derrière la fenêtre de sa
chambre
intrigué je m'approche et je vois un
oiseau dans le jardin un peu rapidement
je fais demi tour en me disant ce n'est
donc que ça mais avant de repasser la
porte je me ravise
je refais demi tour et je décide de me
mettre au même niveau que marie je
décide de regarder avec les yeux de
marie allongée à plat ventre au sol je
décide de redécouvrir la magie d'un
oiseau qui se lave tout ces petits
gestes précis pour faire sa toilette la
façon de se mouiller la tête
les pâtes encore sur le bord c'est vif
picotements de bec pour raviver ses
plumes et les remettent en place
et puis sa façon tout d'un coup de se
jeter tout entier dans la flaque en
s'agitant comme un petit fou quand je
regarde avec les yeux de marie je
ressens je ressens c'est goutte d'eau
qui mouillent mes plumes je deviens
petit oiseau qui me délecte de ces
quelques minutes de bonheur profond je
savoure la fraîcheur de l'eau j'entends
les clapotis de l'eau versée cette
tranquillité
je savoure tout ça met tout est en
suspens
non je deviens bête mais non bien au
contraire je me reconnecte je réapprends
je renais merci marie alors plus je
regardais vivre ma fille plus je faisais
le constat que j'étais bien limité par
rapport à elle d'abord je ne faisais pas
le grand écart 50 fois par jour
deuxièmement malheureusement pour moi je
ne parlais pas le langage mouche et
troisièmement je n'étais pas émerveillé
de regarder un oiseau dans le jardin
alors le verdict tombe naturellement si
je me compare à ma fille je suis
handicapé je reviens sur ce que je vous
disais au début il y à 7 ans nous
décidions avec nicolas mon mari et nos
six enfants de partir dans un voyage fou
certains nous dissuader nous assurant
des lendemains douloureux mais sûr de
nos aspirations
nous partions sur ces chemins inconnus
décidé à quitter notre confort à sortir
de nos terres non pas par volontarisme
mais par amour
oui il y à 7 ans nous décision par amour
d'adopter cette petite marie dont je
viens de vous parler
marie et porteuses d'une trisomie 21
et c'est même drôle la vie est pleine
d'humour car aux yeux de beaucoup
c'est grande aventure familiale était
perçu comme la fin de notre couple de
notre tranquillité de notre famille est
bien loin de mourir à petit feu
on s'est rendu compte petit à petit
qu'on était en train de vivre mieux
alors ce chromosome en plus de marie
chance ou malchance
et bien tout dépend de la façon dont on
voit les choses
tout dépend de la façon dont on se
positionne en général
c'est toujours un plus d'avoir quelque
chose en plus des autres surtout dans
notre société où on court toujours après
le plus du plus du plus du plus pour
avoir plus et puis vous m'en remettrai
un petit peu plus au passage certains
parlent de chromosomes en plus et
d'autre du chromosome entre aux
problèmes de langage encore une fois et
bien tout dépend du référentiel dans
lequel on se situe alors moi ce soir je
vous invite
je vous invite à rentrer dans notre
nouvelle lecture de la différence je
vous invite à déchiffrer les messages au
delà des apparences et à comprendre que
le chromosome surnuméraire de marie et
comme un accent circonflexe sur son
génome parce que dans la langue
française l'accent circonflexe laisse
perplexe mais il rend le mot plus
important il le rend même plus beau
coiffé de son chapeau on lem l'écrire
plus que les autres parce qu'il est
rigolo il est même plus joli comme un
grain de beauté sur une peau lisse et
bien pour nous le chromosome
surnuméraire de marie et ce grain qui la
rend tellement belle ce petit chapeau
pointu qui lui donne ses yeux deux
chinoises et bien la trisomie
c'est comme cet accent circonflexe au
début ça perturbe
ça laisse perplexe ça dérange parce que
évidemment on se cogne à cette
différence on se fait mal on ne voit que
ça on est même blessé par nos pertes de
repères
et puis petit à petit on écoute regarde
on apprend on réfléchit bouscule nos a
priori on explose nos référentiels et on
aime ou on aime et je vais même aller
plus loin
on ne veut plus se passer de ses enfants
car ils nous propulse en dehors de nous
mêmes il nous libère de
n ils nous sortent de notre grotte comme
dit platon parce que c'est parce que ce
qui est monstreux seller représentation
déformée que l'on se fait de la réalité
du handicap alors et si on vivait au
lieu de penser la vie et si on prenait
soin de l'autre au lieu de se donner des
excuses
et si on se risquer au vide à l'aridité
à l' angoisse pour essayer de refaire
rire nos déserts il s'est tout
simplement on risquait dé mais alors un
aimant mari beaucoup pensaient que nous
signons la vie la fin de notre famille
et bien c'est tout le contraire qui
s'est passé
ce fut une renaissance le début d'une
autre vie marie nous avait tous piqués
de 7 et non ce désir de voyager et
d'aller à la rencontre d'autres voyages
alors eh bien nous nous sommes remises
en route en décembre 2007 mme notre
petite fille est tombée dans nos neuf
coeur une petite marie garance sans
chromosomes en plus marigard ans elle
est là un fauteuil roulant plus marica
ans elle ne peut pas être alimentée par
la bouche comme nous alors elle a une
petite valve directement relié dans
l'estomac un nombril en plus en fait
autant mari nous a permis de découvrir
des domaines de compréhension un voile
s'est levé
autant marigard ans nous permet
d'approfondir ce parcours initiative
alors pour vous expliquer ma révérence
par exemple elle a la faculté du relais
drire mais le mot est faible car quand
elle rit on pleure car rien n'est plus
beau c'est aussi doux que le route de au
caramel
notre enfance de mamie colette marigard
ans quand elle rit notre coeur se remet
à battre comme si on était en salle de
des chocs avec le défibrillateur sur la
poitrine
elle rit par exemple quand elles sont le
vent lui caresser la joue et lui
soulever les cheveux et moi eh bien ma
peau est devenu tellement riche avec le
temps que je ne le sens plus souvent
marigard ans elle montre sa joie sa joie
immense
quand elle sent les millions de grains
du sable chaud de la plage coulé entre
ses orteils et bien moi comme un
dinosaure à la poutre août années comme
un bulldozer qui ne me connecte plus ça
mes sensations je ne ressens plus cette
joie immense de marché sur six sable
chaud marie garance est extrêmement
fragile sa vie ne tient qu'à un fil
elle a beaucoup de mal à respirer ça
déglutition est quasiment inexistante
car elle fait beaucoup de crises
d'épilepsie son petit cerveau ne permet
pas de maîtriser toutes ces fonctions
vitales
alors chez nous c'est certain mais matin
n'ont plus la même saveur
quand on entend la respiration de marie
garance oblige couloir
quelle joie c'est à chaque fois une
victoire de la vie sur la mort c'est à
chaque fois un jour de plus donnée aux
fermes et quel cadeau alors grâce à
l'immense fragilité de marie garance et
bien par effet miroir on comprend que
notre vie aussi ne tient qu'à un fil
on perçoit enfin notre finitude et on
comprend
qu'il est temps d'aimer maintenant avant
qu'il ne soit trop tard
il est temps d'aimer aujourd'hui parce
qu'on ne sait pas si demain existera
alors si vous avez bien suivi
vous avez donc compris qu'avec nicolas
nous avions six enfants naturels quand
nous avons eu l'immense chance d'adopter
nos deux petites mari alors
naturellement vous allez penser que nous
sommes passés à côté de nos six enfants
pour nous occuper de nos deux petites
filles fragiles et bien c'est tout le
contraire encore une fois qui s'est
passé elles nous ont permis de nous
réveiller de notre endormissement il
était temps parce que comme il était dit
normaux et ben il était parfaitement
taillé pour rentrer dans les tiroirs
conçu pour eux tout devrait se passer
comme dans les livres à yop chacun sa
case c'est bien rangé rien qui dépasse
c'est rassurant non
résultat nous étions en train de passer
à côté de leur richesse individuelle car
tous sont uniques
tous sont différents tous ont des choses
en plus et tous ont des handicaps
alors on a compris qu'il était temps de
les aimer pour ce qu'ils sont et non
pour ce qu'il devrait être
je comprends que la vie n'a de sens
finalement que si on aime totalement que
si on prend dans nos bras la totalité
sans laisser de côté ce qui ne nous
plaît pas car amy c'est ça c'est
recommencer se relever après la chute
c'est ça qui nourrit notre âme et qui
forgent notre vrai langage parce que
l'âme ne réfléchit pas elle transpire et
puis la vie elle ne se pense pas elle se
vit
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]